-Our next guest is
a voting rights organizer,
former Georgia
state representative,
and best-selling author.
Her new book,
"While Justice Sleeps,"
is available now.
Please welcome back
to the show Stacey Abrams.
Hello, Stacey.
How are you?
-I am well.
Thank you. How are you?
-I'm very well.
Your book is called
"While Justice Sleeps."
Last time you were here,
it was right before the
runoffs in Georgia.
Both the candidates,
you were supporting won
and we talked
about you sleeping
and I'm just wondering
if you managed to take
a celebratory nap at the end
of those runoff elections.
-I did, indeed.
But I woke up
to voter suppression
coming back in force, so,
I may not do another nap
for a while.
-You are a very busy perso
and, while we greatly
appreciate your efforts
in trying to stop the tide
of voter suppression laws
that are, obviously,
a huge problem right now,
you also have time
to write books.
This is very exciting because,
this is not your first novel
but it is your first novel
with your actual name on it.
You've written
under a pen name before.
I'm wondering --
obviously, you knew
you were the author
of those books.
Was it different,
writing a book,
knowing that everyone
who picked it up
would know it was written
by the Stacey Abrams?
-No, I think what was differen
was knowing people might care.
When I wrote the first
eight novels,
Selena Montgomery was much mor
exciting than Stacey Abram
and so I'm glad that peopl
will actually pick up a book
because my name is on it,
instead of despite my name
being on it.
-This is an idea that you
came up with 10 years ago
and publishers passed
on it then.
What was it?
Did the times change?
Did the circumstances change
Were people just more excite
that you wanted
to put your name on a book
What changed that made this book
a book for today?
-When I first proposed the boo
and had written it,
I had a corrupt president
who was involved
in international intrigue
and a swing justice
on the Supreme Court,
who may decide
the fate of the world,
and that was dismissed
as being too absurdist
and not quite
contemporary enough.
So, you know, we had some
intervening activities
between 2008 and 2020,
and so, the book
suddenly seemed relevant.
-We talked
about "Queen's Gambit"
last time you were on the show
and how wonderful
that television show is.
There is a chess element
in this as well.
You want to make it clear
you had your chess element
10 years ago.
-I did. I did.
Started writing this in 2008
long before I knew
of the "Queen's Gambit."
-I also want to ask about this
You have, I believe,
five siblings, is that right
-Yes.
-And they work
in very diverse fields,
professional fields,
and, yet, they all give yo
feedback on your books.
Is this feedback
that you are open to?
Do you like having sibling
like this?
-I am grateful to them
when I ask,
I am sometimes grateful
when they answer,
but they're an incredible
phalanx of really smart people
and that's much cheaper
than having to pay an expert
to tell you things,
faster than Google.
You get immediate feedback
you can ask more questions
refine the issues,
and you don't have
to press 1 or 2 to get to,
you know, an operator.
They just answer when I call
-You have a federal judge
in the family?
That's correct?
-I do.
-Is it a biologist?
-Yes. So Jeanine
is an evolutionary biologist
-These are very helpful fields
for the kinds of books
you're writing.
-Social worker,
an anthropologist.
We run the gamut.
-Is it true -- I believe
it was the social worker
that talked you
out of a car chase?
-Yes!
He cut my scene.
I thought it was fun,
but he literally thought
the scene took too long, so.
-Oh, he thought it was just --
he just wanted you
to get to what was happening
-Exactly.
-I will say I love
a good car chase,
but more on film.
-Yes.
-When I'm reading a car chase,
I kind of want to see it
a little bit,
so I'm going to side
with your brother on that one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys also have
a family book club.
Is this a deal where everybody
actually reads the books?
-We do, and we can tell
if you haven't,
so what happens is
we set a deadline
for doing the book club
and then someone calls.
One of us will call
our older sister,
who's responsible
for convening us,
and somebody has to come u
with an excuse
for why they didn't get it
done this week.
You don't want to be the perso
who does it every time,
so you'll have this like
phone tree of,
"Well, I did it last time!
And then, we get Andrea
to give us permission
to put off the book club
for another week.
-[ Laughs ]
Your mom, a librarian back
in the day, correct?
-Yes. Correct.
-Does she participate as well?
-She does not, so it's jus
a sibling book club
and we've heard about the fact
that we are
just a sibling book club
and we don't include my mother
so please don't bring it up.
[ Laughter ]
-Is this an active choice,
to not have her participate?
What do you think would go
wrong, if she was there?
-There are six of us who hav
a robust conversation
and we read
varying degrees of books
and we don't circumscribe
our language, always,
in our discussion
about plot points.
My mother went from being
a librarian to being a pastor,
so I will let you infer
from there
-[ Laughs ]
-why there might be a proble
with having her
on the call the whole time
-Hey, you know, you've bee
a guest on this show a lot
and I was very touched
by something in the book
because I know you're not
on only this late night show
You've also been
on Stephen Colbert,
of whom I'm a great fan,
and this is really cool.
In the book, it says,
"Nigel rocked slowly.
'The president wasn't please
with my press conference.
I'm booked on Colbert
for tonight's broadcast
and also Seth Meyers.'"
And I just thought
it was so cool
that you mentioned us as well.
[ Laughter ]
Meant the world to me.
Because my feelings would've
obviously, been hurt,
if it would've been just lik
sort of exclusive to Stephen
-You're anticipating -- look
there's going to be a show
about the book.
You assumed that I was jus
going to put both of you
in competition.
I like to keep things separate
-Well, this is true.
I want to talk
about this as well.
The book is,
we just found out today,
going to be a television show.
Is that something that
you had ever thought possible,
when you were first
sitting down to write it?
-No. I mean, look,
I was surprised
somebody finally published it,
so getting a TV show
in this century is awesome
But, no, I love television
as you know,
and I'm just very excited
that Working Title
and Universal are excited
about doing this with me.
-I feel like a difference
between this visit
to you on our show
and previous times
is your backdrop now
seems very professional to me.
-Oh, thank you.
-I feel like I've seen you a lot
in your home, maybe in sort of
a nondescript office,
and now, this is very showbiz.
It's amazing.
The minute your book
gets optioned,
look at your background.
[ Laughter ]
-I've also been double vaxxed,
man, so I can go outside.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you tell us any reaso
to not be pessimistic
and depressed
about how effectively Republican
state legislatures seem
to be passing
voter suppression bills?
-I think we should be concerned,
we should pay attention,
but we've also been
very effective.
We've seen some of the worst
pieces come out of those bills
and, even though
they continue to pass,
more and more people
are aware of it.
And we still have time
for Congress to take actions
and it's working
on it right now
and I believe that we can
actually have democracy
that is free and fair
and accessible to all,
so, I'm going to keep pushing.
-You have been --
we've shown clips of you here --
very effective
when you've gone
in front of Senate committees,
when you've gone in front
of House committees.
How much preparation do you have
to put into those appearance
and how much of it is just
at this point,
you know your stuff and there'
nothing to worry about?
-I'm generally up to speed
You know, before I did
the last Senate appearance
I did ask my team to give me
as much detail as they could
Luckily, I was able to retai
that information in time
for some questions that wanted
sort of a list of challenges
But I am incredibly grateful
to the Fair Fight team.
They keep me well prepped.
I mean, they're
like my siblings,
only, we pay them
to do their work.
-Now that you are known
as, obviously,
not just an advocate
for voting rights,
but also as an author
of fiction,
do you feel like people in D.C
are now a little worried that,
if they behave in a way that i
both bad and memorable,
they will become fictionalized
in one of your books?
-Given that my colleagues
at the state legislature
occasionally found themselve
in the book
and the current speaker of the
House for the Georgia House is
in "While Justice Sleeps" --
he knew about it 10 years ago,
he's still in there --
I just warn people,
"You may be in the book
and you might die."
[ Laughter ]
-That's very nice.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean --
Now, if someone is represented
in one of your books
and they die, that sometimes
is just you serving the plot
-Absolutely.
-That is not a negative commen
on their personality.
-Absolutely. Or they were
in the car chase
and they got cut out,
so, there you go.
-Yeah, a fate worse than death
is getting cut out,
which, thank God,
didn't happen to me
because I made it in the book.
There it is right there, proof
[ Laughter ]
See? It's so great.
Where do you do your writing
Because I feel like
that's the thing
that is most interesting
to people
who can't believe that anyon
could sit down and write a book.
What is your perfect situation
-So I have a secretary desk.
You pull it out
and it lays flat.
Put my laptop on top
and start writing.
Or my dining room table.
Depends on how good
the light is,
whether I can actually get
to the desk
because it's covered with stuff.
Wherever my computer will fit,
that is where I sit to write
-And, when you write,
do you tend to do a lot at onc
or are you someone who grabs
an hour here or there?
Because I find I need a lo
of uninterrupted time,
just to percolate.
-I usually have half a day
to a day set aside
I will schedule to write
because, for me,
writer's block isn't
that I can't think of it.
It's, "I don't want to do it
I don't like words anymore
I don't want to write it.
Never mind,"
and then I've got to give
myself time to get past that
and then to sit down
and do my work.
-And are there times
where you sort of break
maybe a plot problem you had
or you find a way of sayin
something that delights you?
Do you celebrate it all
while you're writing
or do you know in the moment
like, "Oh, yeah,
this is a really good one,
right here"?
-No, I will get happy.
I had one book,
not "While Justice Sleeps" -
I had another book
where my character
was supposed to be going
out onto a cliff
and she ended up in a cave and I
had no idea why she was ther
and it took like three day
to figure it out.
When I realized
why she was there,
it made perfect sense,
so I sometimes have to wai
for the plot to reveal itsel
to me in greater detail.
-And how much do they come
to you with the cover of a book?
Like how many different versions
do you see before you sign off
-This was actually the ver
first cover they recommended
I thought it was evocative
of the story
and it was really awesome
to see my name on the book
But I really loved the colors.
I just thought it was
a really well done cover
and the team at Doubleday
has been amazing to work with.
-On the Selena Montgomery books,
was there no author photo
on the back of the book jacket
-Oh, no, no. My face is
in every one of my books.
When I say that nobody cared
this was not self-deprecation.
Just nobody cared.
[ Laughter ]
-It was something like this,
but just, right here,
it said "Selena Montgomery"?
-Yes.
And then, if you look
at the copyright,
it said "Stacey Abrams."
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like they're going
to pull you
in front of the Senate for that.
-[ Laughs ]
-I feel like they're going
to have
a lot of questions about that.
[ Laughter ]
-I will refer them
to this show for answers
because that's
what everyone should do.
-Oh, well, it'll be nice for you
to talk about this show.
[ Laughter ]
-I will talk about this show
so much from now on.
-Stacey,
if that's your real name,
[ Laughter ]
it is always a delight
to see you.
Congratulations on the book.
-Seth, thank you so much
and thank you for being
so generous
and such a tremendous show
[ Laughter ]
-Nice try.
"While Justice Sleeps"
is available now
wherever books are sold,
but please support
your local
and independent bookstores